Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
on Doctor Who we got to witness one of the
big moments in human history, one of the future
moments I guess.
The episode also paid reference to a big classic
who episode Planet of the Spiders from the
Third Doctor’s Run.
I feel like everyone is going to have a lot
to say about Clara after they get a chance
to see it.
Really good news too, The Doctor Who Legacy
people gave me a game code to add to my giveaway.
I’ll explain how that works at the end,
but the regular weekly giveaway is still running.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment. So two different giveaways
this week.
Spider Time, Top 5 Moments. careful for spoilers
if you haven’t seen the episode yet. I’ll
wait just a sec...okay, here we go.
Number 5 - Mothballing The Shuttle Program
Bites The United States In The Ass
I am a huge space geek and a huge NASA geek,
so back in 2011 when they ended the Space
Shuttle Program I was super pissed. I understand
it’s a money thing, and I don’t want to
talk politics and military spending but I
was so happy that Doctor Who wagged it’s
finger at the whole thing.
The whole episode was a cautionary tale about
the value of the Space Program in every country.
The United States just teamed up with India
to explore Mars, so the lesson isn’t totally
lost. But you get the idea. Ignore Space at
the peril of hatching moon creatures.
Mexico deserves a high five for spending the
money to build a mining operation on the moon
too. It sucks they didn’t find any minerals,
but when the moon is really an egg there’s
nothing you can do about it.
I just love that they literally had to pull
the space shuttle out of a museum and fix
it to go back to space.
In reality right now, the United States and
other countries that want to go to the International
Space station typically use Russia’s Space
Program.
There is a lot of international cooperation
just because spaceflight is so expensive.
Number 4 - The Doctor Takes Courtney to the
Moon to Make Her Feel Special
It’s really hard to tell how seriously he
took fixing Courtney and Clara’s feelings
in the episode. I’ll talk about Clara in
a sec, she’s a whole different story.
What was going on with Courtney was that the
Doctor wasn’t trying to be mean, he was
off-handedly dismissing her.
I felt like the comments he made at the end
of the episode implied that the female president
was supposed to be Courtney.
There’s some logic issues with that but
the timeline is about right. Courtney would
be about 48 years old but she’s British,
so she’d be the Prime Minister, not the
President.
I took issue with Clara at the end of the
episode, even if the doctor was being callous
in his treatment of them. He’s not there
to make your decisions for you.
And he totally delivered on Courtney, she
walked away being the first woman to walk
on the moon’s surface and she probably grows
up to become the prime minister or someone
amazing.
Courtney was awesome in this episode, Clara
was not.
Number 3 - The Doctor Can’t See Fixed Moments
In Time
I don’t think this was giant foreshadowing
for the finale or anything. The Doctor has
made this same comment many times before.
He’s not lying, there are always going to
be moments in time he can’t see clearly.
But the key word is “Clearly” he still
has an idea for what could happen and he can
make deductions based on all the available
information.
The thing that confused me a little was when
they were on the beach watching the creature
hatch and he had that speech about humanity
spreading itself to the stars. He seemed really
sad.
I wonder if he was thinking about the events
of Utopia and The Sounds of Drums.
Where, in the very very far future the Master
tricks the last living humans into becoming
the Toclafane.
Number 2 - Planet of The Spiders
The Spiders were really a small part of the
episode but it was a nice reference to the
Third Doctor’s last story Planet of the
Spiders.
At the end of that he regenerated into the
Fourth Doctor so not only was it really creepy
because giant spiders, it was also a big moment
in Doctor Who history.
I loved that Courtney was able to neutralize
them with Windex. It’s funny sometimes how
Doctor Who as a series will take a lot of
care in teasing big things, then just throw
them away.
All the promos for the episode made you think
these spiders were going to be the big challenge
but they were just a a smudge on the window
of the TARDIS. Nothing a little windex won’t
fix.
and my Number 1 moment - The Moon is an Egg
They were very non-specific about what kind
of creature it was, the Doctor just says it’s
the only one of it’s kind. But it is capable
of fertilizing it’s own eggs. So I can reproduce.
They just have a gestation period of 100 Million
Years.
There was actually a Star Trek Next Generation
Episode where they did a giant Space Baby.
The enterprise has to help it hatch and then
it imprints, thinking the ship is it’s mother.
That would be kind of funny if a space baby
thought the TARDIS was it’s mother.
The TARDIS is alive too, but technically it
doesn’t reproduce, it grows like a tree.
That would be fun to watch, watch a TARDIS
being born or grown or however you want to
think about it.
That’s what we need for the next big Doctor
Who Anniversary. We need a scene on Gallifrey
where we get to watch TARDISes being built.
Somebody start a letter writing campaign to
Moffat.
Let me know what your favorite moment was,
the tumblr jokes, the Moon Hatching?
This was one of my more favorite episodes
so far.
Here’s a few of the better references I
spotted. If there’s any you saw just write
them in the comments.
First was the Neil Armstrong Speech Courtney
Woods did, One Giant Leap for a Thingy Thing.
Who needs to pay attention in history class,
definitely not Courtney.
The Doctor uses a Yo-Yo that looks just like
the one Tom Baker always played with. He used
it to test gravity but Peter Capaldi uses
it to save Courtney.
There was something of a geronimo moment when
the Doctor lept over the cliff, he didn’t
say it but I feel like we were all thinking
it.
then there was all the tumblr. This was great.
The official Doctor Who team has one of the
biggest accounts on Tumblr. They interact
with the fandom there more than any other
social media platform.
But I feel like the doctor yelling at courtney
about posting pictures of him was a reference
to all the leaked pictures from the set.
There were actually a lot of pictures from
this episode of them filming on the beach
in the space suits. I think he was referencing
those, along with all the other leaked pictures
from this year.
Let me know if you spotted any other big references.
Overall I gave the episode an A minus, The
story was really grand and I love how it connected
several big moments in Doctor Who history,
between the third doctor and the toclafane.
Courtney Woods acquitted herself nicely, I
know
a lot of you weren’t huge fans of her last
week but Clara was really the person I didn’t
like in this episode.
I feel like she’s forgetting who the Doctor
really is. They blur the lines a lot between
Capaldi being a total alien and being her
best friend. Deep Breath made it explicit
that The Doctor was not here for our amusement.
And he’s not here to make decisions for
us. So watching Clara get upset and cry like
a baby wasn’t fun.
I feel like she’s not learning, maybe that
will change in a future episode. But eventually
she has to come to the conclusion that The
Doctor is not an all powerful god watching
over her. She has to learn to take responsibility
for her choices.
You can’t get mad at someone when all they
promised you was an adventure, the doctor
never promises you won’t die.
Definitely a great episode, I’m really wondering
what Danny Pink’s really bad day was about.
We will definitely learn about that, so don’t
worry.
I’ll be posting my Q&A video tomorrow, so
leave all your questions.
Just to explain the Doctor Who Legacy Giveaway,
it’s a game code you can use to claim free
stuff in the game. It’s good for the first
50,000 people, so everyone should be able
to use it.
It’s written in the description below with
a link to the game if you don’t have it
yet.
That’s in addition to the regular giveaway.
Right now click here for the Q&A, I’ll add
the annotation as soon as I post it and click
here for my Doctor Who challenge Video.
Thanks for watching, let’s all high five
and I’ll see you tomorrow!